what's this sunburnt fella saying this
show just breaks my heart man
what up brandon what up theo i'm trevor
from east texas got a quick
king hold on pause it real quick this is
his ac picture huh this guy looks like
he's in nasa but they don't wear any
helmets dude this guy
has some sunburn
he's a nasa bro that's what he looks
like nasa bros
no helmets no just space
east texas got a quick king interesting
for you uh
getting your picture with somebody that
you consider a superstar if you see them
out in public
and they're not like going to the
bathroom or eating with their family or
anything do you
get a picture with them or do you just
respect their space and leave them alone
from your point of view what what do you
think also
while i got you here i'm trying to get
it quick rip my drip brennan
waited three weeks for this bad boy i
know you see me filling out this double
xl
oh damn fine oh
lion green j ones the theos gang bro
anyway it's a huge fan of the show keep
doing what you do in game buzz buzz
gang bro that dude will meet you at 270
man
yeah 260. straight up that guy is big
man
that's a double x oh you could slaughter
that guy you know and sell his meat
it's a big-ass nasa employee oh i'd have
a cup you know i'd have a couple pounds
of that guy what's his name victor
it was uh i thought it was tyler
yeah i think tyler who who's the last
picture you gotta
who's the last celebrity you gotta pick
with i say leave them alone
well here's what you do if you're a boss
busboy in tucson arizona
in uh the late 90s you bring as much
unordered food as you can to their table
if it's kevin costner
that's what i did that's what you did
yeah you go i love water world man i'll
give [ __ ] what they say water world
wasn't out yet
in the 90s yeah brendan what'd you say
to him huh
what'd you say to him i just brought a
bunch of bread and rolls over there
was he cool 40. he's like what am i
gonna do with all this like they had to
stop me they gave me a break at work
dave and we never had breaks there
wasn't breaks
hey theo want to take a break once you
leave kevin for a little bit
in the 90s he was a huge star oh he was
dude
he was a legend yeah and him and the guy
from fresh prince of bel air came in the
young fella not will
smith alfonso riviera yeah
he came in he's great people are fired
up carlton he's the host of uh
america's uh what is that the game show
yeah which one he took over bob saget oh
america's
funniest videos yeah oh good for him
yeah
um that's cool man
i did a golf tournament with me too
isn't that weird
nice guy where'd you do it at in florida
oh
so that would kind of be a fun segment
if people send in like legit old school
home videos that were taking on like a a
camera or something from when their
childhood
our own version or people send this
picture of them with celebrities
that's that too there's that
i like them both i like them both i love
home movies like the old school ones
like when
you're just someone's following around
to family oh yeah christmas or something
nothing happens i don't know they always
show a little bit of that on like murder
shows and stuff yeah that's awesome
sounds like nick has a plan yeah right
alan grew up in a good home it says yeah
they show them like running with a gift
nick you've been hanging out with chin
too much
yeah i was just going to say it's gone
now but do you have the picture of
you with your new axe chin oh you got a
new axe what to kill them little fish
yeah i thought it was an axe but
everyone's calling it a hatchet i guess
when it's a smaller version of an axe
axe or longer probably a hatchet maybe
you read my side of the mountain
what depend what part of uh town you're
in some people might call it a tomahawk
possibly tomahawk too
that porter house that tomahawk that
time that what you got
it's an east wing isn't hatchet a book
can you air drop me yeah yeah it is a
book
yeah that's the book i'm talking about
hatches that's what yeah i was like wait
there you go and why the [ __ ] did you
get it chin
you know i'm going camping recently so
just chop up some firewood hey man
brother
hey oh you're going camping friday
hatchet thursday and friday match it's a
good book here's chin right here with
that hat did you post that video open up
like it's a box of [ __ ] jays or
something it's one of the
it was it was a really good surprise oh
you think you'd previously open this
post come in a week later
yeah yeah you open it went all right
let's run this back get your camera out
it finally came in oh
i'm happy it's a week early it's a nice
it's a very nice hatchet thank you that
is a nice [ __ ] hat and what do you
what are you going to do with that chop
wood
sound like a murderer bro he's selling
some of this kind of there's a hatchet
book
yeah yeah it won that silver medal thing
this is a book brennan it's a
did your mom read it to you or what no
i'm trying to describe it
you read it in school yeah it's like if
somebody took a piece of paper like a
bunch of little stacks of paper and
put it like a like a story in it
it's like a stack of them that's cool do
you have your degree controls
i might agree on my phone i think dude
imagine getting a college degree right
now like
what are you gonna do with it yeah yeah
yeah what are you gonna do with that i
don't know
[ __ ] you to do with it i don't know
where mine's at i don't know would you
get your degree in again
uh business and sociology oh wow smart
guy huh
wow yeah yeah what did you major in
uh cheerleading
damn about anything else yeah damn bro
she's killing the cheer game
damn that's all you can do dog yeah
defense bruh yeah